welcome to the newshour u.s president
joe biden has laid out his strategy for
the middle east at a summit of gulf
leaders and other regional heads of
state addressing the meeting in saudi
arabia biden said the u.s would not walk
away from the region and he said his
country remains committed to ensuring
iran never gets a nuclear weapon
let me state clearly
that the united states is going to
remain an active engaged partner in the
middle east
as the world grows more competitive
and the challenges we face more complex
is only becoming clearer to me
that how closely interwoven america's
interests are
with the successes of the middle east
we will not walk away
and leave a vacuum to be filled by
china russia or iran
will seek to build on this moment with
active principle american leadership
we call upon iran as a neighboring
country with whom we share religious and
cultural ties to cooperate with the
countries of the region in order to be
part of this vision by adhering to
international law not interfering in the
internal affairs of other countries and
cooperating with the international
atomic energy agency and fulfilling its
obligations in this regard
well joining me now here in the studio
is al jazeera senior political analyst
marwan bashar marwan can we start with
what joe biden's been saying why do you
think he felt the need to say that the
u.s was not going to abandon the region
because there's been a sense at least
since the u.s withdrew from afghanistan
and some of the administration officials
have been making clear that they're
going to be focusing more on russia and
china rather than
on deploying troops to the middle east
that created a lot of anxiety
among many of america's allies notably
those sitting there in the summit
and hence it was important for the
american president to make clear that
america is not going anywhere if
anything
america is truly is true is
reprioritizing
but if anything
withdrawing from afghanistan will free
more resources
for the gulf region in the middle east
let's not forget of course what uh biden
has called saudi arabia in the past he's
called it a pariah state nevertheless he
has gone there at a time in which the
u.s is looking to
shore up its supplies of energy
absolutely so i think there is a
national interest here
and uh biden is not hiding it he's
making it very clear that he's there to
serve american national interest even if
it is at the expense at the expense
of uh human rights uh whether it's human
rights of saudis uh egyptians
uh palestinians or whoever but be that
as it may america comes first america is
first and hence
he is eager to
uh reassert america's influence in the
region
uh reshape old alliances with the likes
of saudi arabia uae egypt iraq and so on
and so forth and make clear that america
is re-prioritizing but it's one going
anywhere my fear is while he's getting
some of his
mission accomplished
what we're what would what we're seeing
slowly but surely is
basically the evolving of a cold war in
the middle east with iran russia and
china on the one hand the united states
saudi arabia abu dhabi egypt and israel
on the other hand the one thing that
also has dominated this summit uh in in
jeddah also are
um
to do with the palestinian situation
without a doubt it's the it's the
elephant in the room it's what unites
all the gcc leaders along with their
regional partners um but of course you
know shortly after biden left uh israel
there were these rocket attacks from
gaza
what sort of tone do you think biden's
presence in the middle east has set what
sort of
problems has it reignited
look i i think uh and during the summit
um
we've seen the emir of qatar probably
articulate the best possible position
about double standard
and he's basically spoke about
international law international norms
and international values
and he said we need to be consistent
about the applications of these
so-called international values laws
and
and norms and it couldn't be simply
applied somewhere but not applied
elsewhere it couldn't be applied in
ukraine but not applied in palestine so
palestine really came to life by all
speakers in the summit uh today but i
think the amir of qatar put it very
clearly when he said
basically to the american president
we can't accept israel expanding illegal
jewish settlements instead of
advancing
peace settlement
in palestine and i think the message to
a lot of the presence there were you
know the abrahamic accords
in the end of the day they are not used
as leverage against israel in order to
pressure it to bring a solution to
palestine if anything
it is leaving the palestinians with very
little hope
that
their occupation will be ending anytime
soon all right bashar al jazeera senior
political analyst thank you
well joining me here from our dog our
headquarters is our white house
correspondent kimberly halcott staying
with this story kimberly i mean
obviously an awful lot has been made of
this fist pump between uh joe biden and
mohammed bin salman but beyond that do
you think the president got what he
wanted out of this trip
yeah that's right a lot has been made
about that fist bump and that is going
to be a problem likely for the u.s
president when he returns to the united
states because it was not well received
in fact the u.s president ended up
having to do a little bit of damage
control as a result
saying in fact that he confronted the
crown prince about
the allegations the
suggestion even by the cia that
potentially he ordered the killing of
the washington post journalist jamal
khashoggi back in 2018
and as a result there was a lot of
condemnation about that fist bump
especially from the washington post
publisher
given the fact that jamal khashoggi
wrote for that well-known paper
so moving forward from that was a
challenge for the president but still he
has tried to do that tres marwin is
talking about there reasserting the
united states role
in the middle east in the region is the
priority for this president but there's
no question that those negative
headlines are going to dog the president
for some time in fact uh we've even had
in just the last couple of hours the uh
sort of headlines of the crown prince
himself kind of taking a swipe at the
president
in fact suggesting that the president
really doesn't have the moral high
ground reminding the president of some
of the united states own mistakes as he
calls them reminding and digging up the
sort of past uh sort of bad headlines
for the u.s with respect to the conflict
in iraq the u.s invasion of iraq and of
course the atrocities the u.s committed
its military prison in abu ghraib and
then more recently of course the killing
of our own journalist sharina abu akley
the fact that the u.s president at least
in public did not confront the israeli
government over that murder despite the
fact that
or killing rather despite the fact that
the two investigations point to the
israelis for potentially being
responsible for her death so uh this is
uncomfortable for the u.s president he
now has to go back
he said he came here to get the saudi
government to pump more oil it hasn't
secured that deal and he hasn't been
able to lower the gas prices that
americans would like him to do so
it's going to be difficult for uh the
president right yeah and kimberly on
that note i mean how might all of this
play into domestic politics back home in
the states ahead of the midterms in
november
yeah that's the big problem for the
president because americans are pretty
unhappy with joe biden and they were
unhappy before he made this trip and he
didn't do anything to make it better uh
so it's hard to imagine that his poll
numbers are going to go up and they were
in need of that uh you you compare him
to donald trump and another sort of
unpopular president and the approval
ratings are about the same not much
better in fact in the 30s and that's the
sort of the benchmark of really
bottoming out in the united states and
that's not where you want to be when you
have congressional elections in november
there's not a whole lot of time to turn
things around joe biden needed a win he
didn't get one in terms of the foreign
policy stage and so
he goes back to the united states now
looking absent when americans are
struggling with high inflation high fuel
costs high food prices they're angry at
their president and this president did
nothing to improve that
kimberly many thanks kimberly halcott
our white house correspondent here in
doha forest thanks